comment tu peux fermer mes yeux cette
fois qu'il me quittent le cas d'accord
d'accord là dessus dans ta bulle locales
comme dans nos ventes
[Musique]
alors que l'urgence climatique et
environnementale est de plus en plus
pressante
les nouvelles générations se pose
désormais la question du bien fondé de
la parentalité canada etats unis france
le mouvement childfree comprendre les
100 enfants volontaires et sème
désormais dans de nombreux pays pour moi
c'est vraiment le côté écologique de la
planète fait quand même déjà pas mal
peuple et même surpeuplé
c'est pas vraiment personnage passe
d'ajouter plus de
l'officier m'a arrêté et m'a dit vous
êtes dans une file réservée au
covoiturage
j'ai répondu oui il m'a dit ok est ce
qu'il y a quelqu'un d'autre dans la
voiture j'ai dit oui en montrant mon
ventre brandy est enceinte de 34
semaines presque huit mois elle compte
bien en jouer pour éviter la menthe de
215 euros
je veux pas trop me coller pour les
voitures
hélas alors tout talent je n'avais pas
fait attention j'étais monté un coup
dessus de 90
quand elle prend le mors je suis comme
ça
et
[Musique]
là il a répondu ça ne compte pas il faut
deux personnes physiques j'ai été un peu
choqué et j'ai dit je ne veux pas en
faire une position politique mais vu ce
qui s'est passé dans l'actualité vous
comprenez qu'on peut déjà considérer que
c'est un bébé
un petit massage si tu es bien
[Musique]
regardez ce qu'on peut faire quand on
est hypnotisé
maintenant dormait
il avait préparé son coup avant en bravo
j'étais ministre donc le ministre que je
suis a fait son travail mais simplement
on introduit une espèce de l'ambiance
qui consisterait à dire que voir des
chefs d'entreprise particuliers
étrangers ne seraient mal mais je
l'assumé à fond et en vous regardant
j'ai vu des chefs d'entreprise étrangers
l'horreur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je les ai vu ça a toujours été
officielle avec des collaborateurs j'en
suis fier si l'on crée des emplois en
france j'y suis je suis hyper fier de
cela et vous savez quoi je leur ferai
demain et après-demain traverser les
états unis en trottinette électrique
c'est le pari fou de manuel un français
de 27 ans vivant talent si le but c'est
de partir de los angeles et d'aller
jusqu'à new york maria 5000km tranquille
partie mi-avril de los angeles il roule
environ cinq heures par jour la côte
pacifique le grand canyon à 20 km/heure
emmanuel peut profiter pleinement du
paysage
avec des soucis souci là pour alberto v
cules manifestation alors évidemment un
mouvement qui n'était pas prévu et qui
est en train de retarder l'homme de tête
alberto bettiol un road trip avec une
contrainte de taille trouvé de
l'électricité pour la batterie mais
c'est l'occasion de faire des rencontres
après trois mois passés sur les routes
il n'est plus qu'à 1000 kilomètres de
l'arrivée
quelques précisions pour ce petit
contretemps sur le milieu de la route il
y avait sept personnes qui défendent est
la même cause que la personne qui
s'était adossé au filet lors des matchs
de roland garros
[Musique]
ils sont finalement autonome en énergie
on se fait pas maintenant ah ça on sait
très bien le faire donc ça c'est
vraiment un peu le futur de demain
notamment qui n'ont pas autant de
futurs d'hier bd en fait non